floyeon coler has created around 1 000
trick shots and pocketed a success
this youtube video has racked up well
over 8 million hits
what's just as amazing he's only been
playing since he was 18.
he got a billiard table as a gift for
his 18th birthday then he taught himself
how to play
and more
it seems like it's it's like an yeah
it's like a galaxy of something and you
just
infinitive possibilities it's just
it never stops so that's good because
you never uh never run out of ideas you
never run out of uh of things to
practice it just never stops and that's
that's what i love about it you can't
really master it never if somebody tells
you master the game is probably gonna be
a liar
everybody tends to
try to theorize the game pool but
there is there is like a math and
physics and angles and tangent line and
everything but uh honestly it all come
to instinct
florian coler was born in allsays france
now he's touring the world showing off
his talents
this evening he's booked to put a little
variety into the finals of the swiss
billiard championships on lake geneva
i take it as an art okay so take the
table you think it's a blank paper
and like an artist they try to draw
something nice on it
what i do is sometimes i have an idea
and i put it in a book and whenever it
could be anywhere in the plane you know
sometimes even sleeping you wake up have
an idea have a note and just put it
there
trick shot got its start in the 20th
century
billiards itself the game of shooting
balls into pockets around a table dates
back to the late middle ages
back then the tables were expensive so
it was a game reserved for the upper
classes
almost like indoor cricket
during the course of the 19th century it
acquired a touch of the disreputable
pool halls were dens of iniquity which
attracted artists like vincent van gaal
and polgerga
in the 20th century movies reinforced
the image of billiards as a gambler's
playground
trick shot was not really a sport it was
more of a way for the hustler the player
they're you know playing on the road
trying to make money to
well hustle other people so you're doing
a shot and
give the guy three tries and if he could
make it well
fine if he couldn't make it then you win
his money so that was that was the way
trick shot was
and it's yeah it's the roots of the
sport
floyeon codell now lives in las vegas
and makes good money from trick shot
his professional name is venom because
of what his q does to the table before
he's done
his dvd of his best shots is the best
selling video of its kind
you know it really is about modernizing
the the trick shot so
well it's just you know it's simple take
out take other sports you know the way
they did it is um they
let's take bmx for example you know it's
all
look online videos it's so short fast
paced like
something like epic music type thing and
people don't care how many tries it
takes to make it they just care about
how good he looks
when evening falls he prepares for his
next tour
it's in china where billiards are once
again a symbol of wealth and where
floyeon cole is a genuine superstar